the new york times is a very interesting
report
about more than 100 republicans
including former republican officials
who are seriously looking at abandoning
the republican party and starting their
own third party
there's a great article by zach montague
published late yesterday i believe in
the new york times where he says
more than 100 republicans including some
former elected officials are preparing
to release a letter this week
threatening to form a third party
if the gop doesn't make certain changes
the statement is going to take aim at
former president trump's stranglehold on
republicans the timing of this
could not be uh more uh relevant
given that with the ouster of liz cheney
republican congresswoman from leadership
republicans in the house seem to be
committing
to a trumpian 2022 platform
the preamble to this letter says quote
when in our democratic republic forces
of conspiracy
division and despotism arise it is the
patriotic duty of citizens to act
collectively
in defense of liberty and justice and uh
this is a first step says miles taylor
who's an organizer of the effort if you
recognize that name that's because
taylor
is the former trump era department of
homeland security official who
anonymously wrote that book
condemning the trump administration he
has since acknowledged that
what was originally written anonymously
was written by him
uh he goes on to say quote this is us
saying
that a group of more than 100 prominent
republicans think that the situation has
gotten so dire with the republican party
that it is now time to seriously
consider whether an alternative might be
the only option now we don't yet know
the full scope of who else is signing
this letter
at some point we will when the letter is
released i am not optimistic
that this group of hundred republicans
can actually
make a dent in the pro-trump
republican party of right now and here's
what i mean by that
we've looked at polling that tells us
the voters right now
are basically with trump 70 percent of
them still believe that donald trump
won something like two-thirds said
they would leave the republican party
and follow trump
if trump were to start his own party now
i don't think two-thirds really would
two-thirds are saying that they would
some wouldn't because they would realize
actually
you know maybe i don't want to follow
trump part of that two-thirds wouldn't
just because of laziness it actually
takes some effort to leave the
republican party
some would leave the republican party
and follow trump but would still mostly
vote for republicans so you know we have
to understand that that two-thirds is
not
if trump leaves republicans really lose
two-thirds of their votes
but although trump seems to have met
millions and tens of millions of
republicans that would follow him out
it's not clear to me
that if a hundred republican officials
leave the party that that many voters
follow them
i think that whatever happens with the
republican party in 2022 and 2024
is going to happen from within the
republican party
unless it's trump who bails if you
disagree with me i would love to hear
from you i just don't see any
serious willingness from republican
voters to say
particularly because they're mostly with
trump
if some officials leave i will go with
them
the counterpoint to this is that not
that many have to leave
in order to potentially completely
sabotage the chances of republicans in
2022.
many of these 2022 races are going to be
very tight
um particularly in the senate but in the
house as well
and even if it's true that 70 75 80
of republicans would not even consider
leaving just because
miles taylor is starting some third
party
and i think that that's the case if only
a few of them
do leave and they are disproportionately
voting republicans because remember
particularly in midterms
sometimes half or more of the country
doesn't even vote it doesn't take
that much to potentially completely
upend the chances of republicans at
taking back the house
or the senate in 2022. so we have to
sort of hold both things on the one hand
it is very clear that it's trump who
holds the cards here trump is still
fundraising
uh trump is recreating his
communications with the party
although to a very limited degree of
success those blog posts he's making are
only getting a couple hundred thousand
views
total um and it is still a republican
party
in the house of representatives in the
senate that privately many of them
despise me privately me maybe many of
them despise trump
or don't like the direction he's taking
the party or whatever but
they clearly have calculated if and
until it becomes clear that the voters
are no longer with trump i need
to stay with trump publicly for
self-preservation
to avoid getting the the trump dagger of
saying that person needs to be voted out
or whatever the case may be
so good for these republican officials i
don't think this is going to have much
of an impact whatsoever
i'd love to hear from you about it you
can find me on twitter
at d pacman and remember that monday
memorial day that's not this coming
monday
it's not the next one i believe it's the
one after that monday the 31st
we are doing a one-day membership
special if you would like to be
notified about this membership special
and it is a beauty
just get on my mailing list at
davidpakman.com
if you ever feel like you just don't
have enough time to
read all the books you want to read you
have to check out one of my favorite
apps called
blinkist blinkist takes thousands of
popular nonfiction books
and distills each one down into an
e-book
or audiobook that you can get through in
just 15 minutes where you're getting all
the key takeaways from the book
just imagine how you'll be able to
expand your horizons and knowledge
by being able to soak up all of the
important insights from
10 different books in an afternoon
obviously it's perfect for exposing
yourself to a new book
you otherwise wouldn't have time for or
you can use it to revisit a book you've
already read
or use it to preview a book before you
buy the full version and read it
i recently read a brief history of time
of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy
science they have 27 different
non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com pacman
i've put the link right underneath this
video